und kollegen unterwegs
ich habe schalter bekommen sie von
außerhalb der höhle so weiter geht es
heute wichtig dann verkaufen im laden
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zur
weiteren folge der mega projekt zusammen
mit in line
und ungebremst ungeliebt hallo hallo
vergessen den code kräfte hat er bock
sich einfach mein großvater ende
gefängnis wir können ja jetzt mal hier
loslegen
wieso bist eine quantum ding mit
cointreau sa ich habe ein account bohrer
dabei interessiert zeigt das ja
eigentlich was sind es sind christen
das update ich habe heute am liebsten
macht ein paar monster's ball wie sieht
gefunden ich hatte ja kann bohrer aus
erst mal aufgestellt habe das gehabt es
ganz viele schöne ressourcen ist alles
passiert ist ist hast du eine kiste
sortiert junge hörer das alles passiert
ist hat er hat der dekane bora
freigelegt also 17 diamanten gebe es
ganze klasse an der hamburger ihr müsst
mir echt simon können wir mal in die
ferien mit er will jetzt unsererseits
fehlen
nach dem 15 8 gegen wir mal richtig an
aufnehmen dass du mir so ein bisschen
wie so an fürst wenn wir sehr gern
machen so ja du hast es nicht somit
länger nach mit mit peace-zeichen
arcandor schon okay und auch direkt man
jetzt zuschauern weil im nationalen die
ganze macht oder silvester
natürlich scheint es nicht
mit 4 1 durch das linke urteil bis zum
richtigen greifen kann
ich bin neben dir also ich sehe ich gar
nicht okay ja richtig so dass hier
dieses ganze loch hier das hat als der
karneval geburt ohne bohrer er richtig
abbauen
hier ist alles also die ganzen gänge
hier die ganzen tunnel und wohnen alpha
controller frei geburt vom hochwasser
sind hat und ich zeige euch jetzt
erkannt woran fraktion
der redete die ganze zeit hörten wir mit
mut und ich würde fast sagen
er gerät misst die gute stelle die
nehmen uns mal zu gucken ganz auf die
durch die band ja immer auf mich ich bin
nicht so schnell wie du komm hier soll
im redstone abkaufen hier so viel
stärker hin
grün alles
kurz mal gucken ein ganzes haus holen
okay ist auch mal bei dir vorbei km/h
bekannten gesehen kannst du dich mal
gucken gucken
ich suche noch den anderen grünen
startete das ist alles der grünen starte
ich meine alles aber alles dabei kommt
er zurück wer sich konstituiert also
übernehmen auch skate arbeitet kommt
einfach durch das blaue portal okay das
ist klar
das blaue partei okay gibt lauda der
unfälle ist das dunkelblaue also dass
und wo finde ich das ist immer im lager
aus da war ja genau da wäre ich vorhin
fast schon durch geladen sobald auf
contis kerwe trägst du musst noch einen
abbauen ja erstmal für der camburger
brauchen wir natürlich ein standler oder
mitarbeiter machte mir nicht mehr da
sind so dann nehmen wir uns den akku
bohrer stand jetzt würde und wir so hin
da an den akku bohrer tötet dann kommt
da der kamera um drauf
so da kommt jetzt erst los mit der
russin wesna schon irgendein loch
gefallen weil ihr alter charging eine
spitzhacke nehmen wir einfach mal dieses
spitzenspiels tag hier
so habe ich eine sache nicht vergessen
nämlich ruhe die kommt die hole ich war
schnell ein nein wäre true ich würde
sagen ich bin mir einfach die obsidian
truhe hier mit ich schätze an haus nicht
wo ist dein lagerraum
klickt einfach auf mein haus drauf in
die kassen müssten schon sehen okay so
die hakkani bei einem acker bohrer läuft
jetzt die troja ist mit rein stellen so
so okay wenn erst jetzt kommt jetzt auf
deinen minden inzwischen teil von der
maus darüber denn so genau
siehst du mich nicht hinter dir bis zum
4 1
betreten verboten der angriff ist
unglaublich
bist du bist du so hdfc schaden bekommt
gerade hier simon so auf jeden fall hier
ist der gerade bei der coba kurz da rein
das ist die lehre die wird hinten
angeschlossen da kommt alles rein was
der bohrer abfahrt noch die harmlosen
damit gipfel ist einfach nur ob sie
daran tue hier in bora samstag und einen
16 creation diese braucht er damit der
arbeiten kann braucht der läufer maßstab
genommen aber der stadt läuft mit
charles heston ausstarb geht nicht
kaputt ist unendlich und damit ist auch
der bohrer unendlich als er braucht noch
niemals energie ich habe sozusagen 10
bohrer vormachen kann ich eine riesige
fläche ausbauen ohne es überhaupt
agierte woche seine sprache ist dieser
scheitern
skate system in schalter hier und
konnten hingegen unter gipfeln ich habe
schalter bekommen habt ihr einfach alles
ab kraft gibt es für hessen er strebt
ein programm
jetzt können wir einfach gehen und den
den tempel oder hier stehen lassen macht
einfach weiter und dann sieht dass eine
so auskommen mit vorteil denn er bietet
so lange bis es technisch nicht lange
text also so lange wie diese tunnel hier
sind roma das hat er als geburt dass die
sache aus den dingern rennen
es könnte ja aua machen es könnte dann
machen sie das zurück du willst deine
ganze p ein
hier habe ich nicht was an du hast dich
geschlagen sprecher das geld was sich
schuldig so von abo karte man lebt da
klettere ich muss geld am schluss geht
ab hatte meine sachen erwartet werde ich
noch nie alle noch nie hat man hat eine
ep ein gesammeltes mit einer ich hab'
ich haben über 1000 besucher jetzt auch
die jüngsten mega projekt komm ja ich
will ja abstimmen
es liegt also wollte er sich noch nicht
alle denn der zauberstab auch an der
verliert und haltbarkeit bei den
athleten wieder von alleine auf weil es
der ist sowas wie patching haye kann man
zauberstab aufladen es geht hier kommen
hier geht da rein in das vortrag hält
wann kann man zauberstäbe aufladen jetzt
lege ich in der wand steht einfach auch
weil sie sind sauber drauf das ist auch
bitter was hast du für ein abgefahrenes
werde dass mich der instant getötet
jetzt ist charge ingolstadt ich habe
auch so krass ist ich habe es schwer das
c4 das somalischen
du hast doch sex oder ja gut weil ich
habe auch mit jackson aufgenommen aber
bei mir werden jetzt eine glocke immer
als weiß angezeigt als mir das
vielleicht noch mal patienten einfach
kann ich machen ok so leute also das ist
auf jeden fall arkane bohrer hier der
wollte sowieso schlange in aktion zeigen
und wie ihr seht er hat schon ziemlich
fleißig jetzt gebohrt habe leider kann
mir dabei das macht aber nichts weil die
post ab weil die portale ja auch die
portale machen auch gut licht machen wir
vielleicht einfach mal gar nicht wie ich
den baum bohrer dauert es bei dir du
bist ein problem erforschen bis zum ende
von buch also der gerade boris setzt
eine einsatz finde querry so zu sagen wo
ich bleib hier her das ist so geil hinzu
für rosa diamant hast du dir unten würde
ihn einfach die reste von meinem verein
bohrungen jaja das wasser in der seite
aus gibt da ja das ist aber weiß dass
geiler ist leute alles was er gerade
braucht bord vollautomatische diese
christian rein
doch die ungemeine 18 level wieder dass
er furchtbar immer dabei nicht länger
werde ich gerade deshalb genauso pro
konsums wenn du möchtest kannst levels
sind wieder geben ich habe eine richtig
fette monster falle alter etwas was du
noch nicht erst sehr wohl bleiben
pegelstände aber es ist ganz kurz sehr
gut guck mal schon geschluckt rein hier
sieht man kann es mich an den zauberer
heranführen
dann kann ich gern mal jetzt nicht mehr
weil jetzt sind zu 90 minuten 45 ist
nicht so viel aber ich kann den
aktuellen partner ich mal ein paar aber
wir können gerne mal so eine station
machen wo wir so richtig lange schön das
alles machen ok ja von mir aus kann man
irgendwie selbst dann hab ich die zeit
ich glaube hier ich glaube hier letzten
dakar als nächstes hin
die gänge hier sind super sie schon
wieder eine rohstoffen ab ich glaube ich
ist jetzt der karnevalist habt ihr
einmal ist die eine stelle die welt
nicht so mega zeit die man irgendwann
mitte august oder so und dann nehmen wir
dann in 20 werfer vor bevor der urlaub
das schaffe ich das schon so viel
verriet sonntag eventuell schaffe ich
noch was ist das denn für ein material
das bei dir alles finden nie gesehen
naja wenns denn oberste ich gerne eins
zu weiteren 66 erkundungen und so weiter
hier ist noch redstone irgendwo
irgendwann werde ich den locker nochmal
töten müssen glaube du hast mich
geschlagen was kann ich dafür wenn du
keine spannende versuche einfach mich
töten und ich schlag dich tot ist tot
scheiße ich mache jetzt eine volle
quantum rüstung könnte okay dann müssen
nicht sogar ich mache mir denkt na ja
das müssen wir auch noch machen dann
sehe ich die rezepte nicht mehr so kann
die ganze sachen kann ich gar nicht
ankommen
ich muss einfach mal zaubern 800 folgen
und einfach wie hass auf sich zieht man
aber letztens mit den aufgenommen das
dann auch einfach unproduktiven und
produktiv zusammen und dann haben wir
die wasser hat einfach gepasst aber
immer eine wasserrutsche komme ich mal
auch in meinem erfolge ende nicht
einfach aber ich weiß auch die positive
sache ist einfach spaß macht mir geht es
auch nicht darum wo es nicht da sind
meine rohstoffes ihm viele schöne wetter
ab farmen hier
wer weiter kommt der deckel einfach die
rohstoffe simon mach doch mal was
bei aller liebe zu können dass der auch
mal ein paar rohstoffe du weißt es hat
einfach spaß ganz anderen gegangen
du weißt es sich einfach im leben ok du
kriegst du kriegst du die dinger willst
du lieber saphir oder lieber kohle zu
sperren
ich lass dir den rest von der gruppe ich
glaube hier setzt sich jetzt den arkanen
oder noch einmal nur einmal drehe ich
einmal um hier guckt ganz viel kohle
völlig mining muss ich mir auf jeden
fall erstmal aufbauen und ein schrank
oder ganze energie oder machst du ich
hab nichts zu der geschichte technik
gemacht alter ist ich hab mir gesagt er
läuft komplett ohne energie geboren
übrigens gerade verloren oder ist ich
weiß wurde jetzt darf ich nach menschen
finde ein visum halte mich lieber truhe
haben
nein die wwe draft in das war eine blöde
stelle zum graben egal ob wir noch
richtig gut einstellen da sind wir
gerade etwas wie das abfahren
du brauchst hier habe ich die haben alle
schon alle programme hat diese mental
wieder voll mit stuff geil was man
wirklich nicht brauchen diesem spiel ist
dieses komische nicola doch das war
bereits da habe ich schon richtig viel
verpulvert
ok dann kann der doblo bereit machen wir
ja nicht wie man sehr schnell dass auf
diese blöde stelle gewesen zu abbauen
aber egal was habe ich genug kraft aber
egal wen es etwas ich werde jetzt mal
schnell die sachen abbauen
dann nehme diese truhe hier mitnehme
dritte
bei meiner kanada gp bitte was er wird
in meinem vorstand wählen
bitte bitte jedoch erst fast einnahmen
bitte danke simon dankeschön danke hebel
habe ich alles in grün solange dies
schon fast kaputt weiß bescheid aber ich
hätte auch keine lizenz erhalten selbst
raus gekommen so
bild jörg oder does not be long to you
ich kann nur welche von 60 amis voll gut
so jetzt ist mir hier die truhe rein
oder sogar relativ einfach eigentlich zu
bauen ist jetzt nun passieren dass in
gewissen du willst wieder aber sitzt
wird da den account vorstand drauf dann
den diensten hin welches portal durch
das oder ich mache macht er eine neue
stelle
ich muss noch die mit hohen umsätzen
moment die tore muss noch mehr rohstoffe
den eltern so und jetzt umlegen und los
geht's so korejtek die trümmer ist die
sache natur genommen
zudem war die tour ein das ist mehr als
nur genannt das eben sie dort eben erst
mal sache zumindest ein pony
ja okay da ich weiß nicht mehr was ich
mit diesem schatz soll ich hab davon
voll 46 ja die sind ganz gut mai nicht
irgendwo leuten gerade die glocken ja
bei mir leute nicht schocken
ich bin wieder bei solchen das ist mein
schrank oder jetzt eben noch hin und
dann lese ich meine geschichte vor ich
denke er wollte auch nicht hören oder
absolut wir sind wir hier unten noch
keinen einzigen monster begegnet bei
meiner kann abo vernichtet alles
hauptsache korrigiert sich dahin america
boa ich hab grad schon kupfergewinnung
getötet ok auf jeden fall jetzt wisst
ihr bescheid wie arcandor passiert heute
und ich habe einen plan ist mein
zuschauer ich werde mir hier von diesen
arcandor an werde ich mir so ungefähr
zehn stück machen welch eine riesige
wand fläche gehen die zehn stücke
nebeneinanderstellen ja alles mit so
effizienz so viel spitzhacken und
haltbarkeit und reken pr
und wenn ich einfach ganze ganze berge
einfach damit ausrotten und dann ja
ok ab nach hause wir nehmen es schon 16
jetzt erzählen wie ich wieder nach hause
kommen die portale durch das portal hier
kommst du nach hause
ach du hast mehrere hat er sehr schlau
ich habe zwei ipod ich hab zwei
verschiedene das hier ist jetzt dass das
hier ist jetzt ja simon warum uns
hinsetzen für deine geschichte zu hause
wohnen okay da kommt mein schlafzimmer
wo ist ein schlafzimmer wieder hin
es liegt ein bisschen habe ich das
gefühl wir wissen kein wunder wenn drei
leute auf einmal durch ein portal hier
runter runter geben da es heute auch wir
haben es schon lange aufgenommen
deswegen bitten lassen wird man warum
macht es den coni
ich habe ich nicht ich habe gemacht
sondern dass du gesagt nicht abbauen
dann hab ich aufgehört und dass ich
trotzdem mir gegangen
wilex deckt die hölle
okay okay also leute werden zu nehmen
jetzt mal rot pilz mit nein lass den
schnell einfach davon ja aufs letzte
herzustellen
ich sehe ich mich mal ich zocke die
klingelt wenn wir draußen behinderten
ja ich möchte mit der verbindung die
bürger wissen na gut
auf jeden fall live das ist ja ich nehme
meine gusti nicht sehen du musst nur
heran
mit kapitel 2 das kapitel eins hat jetzt
ungefähr sagen also kapitel eins von
buchkapitel ein buch hieß die wurzel
allen übels hatte 34 seiten kapitel 200
bis jetzt vier seiten und heißt die
suche aber die glocken dinge so laut
dass jetzt meine stimme hoffentlich
übertönen das also kapitel 2
die suche und so zog unser namenloser
held in sein wohl größtes abenteuer
doch davor ganz kurzen haarschnitt
es liegt einfach sehr lange nicht
ausgestanden schönstein dass man erste
service damit werde ich über diesen lady
server kommen okay gibt auch eine mit
einem controller kann worauf müssen die
server mit permira machen also und so
zurück unser namenloser held in seiffen
purist islam trainern und harmlos doch
davon ahnt es ist ein pilz sucher der
hat bis jetzt noch nicht den namen
bekannt gegeben doch davon war zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch nichts obwohl der
pilzsucher weder einen anhaltspunkt noch
eine grobe spur hatte wusste er wie
durch eine magische eingebung genau
welchen weg er einschlagen musste nach
ungefähr einen tagesmarsch erreicht er
eine riesige eiswüste die gegend war
leer
kalt und absolut lebensfeindlich genau
hier war richtig er suchte sich einen
unterschlupf in einer kleinen höhle und
schlug sein echtes lager auf sie traurig
über den verlust von martha und wütend
auf denjenigen der für das alles
verantwortlich ist weg der sich zu bett
plötzlich hört ihr eigenes wohl ein
bedrohliches geräusch von außerhalb der
höhle
weiter gehts heute besticht das war
freute natürlich einkaufen im laden
jeden tag ein bisschen mehr also morgen
geht es weiter und die kirchen doch die
klänge gatti bekloppt wenn euch die
folge feiert mit conny und mit skate
schreibt einfach statt einfache digitale
wollt ihr mehr sehen
mit ein paar leuten zusammen plätzen
folgen ja ziemlich alleine aufgenommen
schreibt einfach in die kommentare
also jetzt zu mir wenn ihr mit simon so
eine ganz lange zauber beibringen folge
wollt schreibt einfach harry potter in
die kommentare
harry potter und und und falls ihr skate
technik erforschen schreibt einfach
inlineskates dem skateboard sondern etwa
in landshut lebt und wenn euch die folge
kein tor gefallen hat und wenn ihr schon
oft folgt noch mehr durch die gegend zu
bohren dann würde ich natürlich über
eine wertung freunden sowie den anderen
beiden denkmal und ich sagen ich hab die
bewertung weil ich bau mir fällt da
nicht einfach items einsammeln zulegt
dabei weil es zunächst dass alle runter
ja ich finde es furchtbar weil die leute
wenn dies so viel zeit dem und den knopf
drücken ja das ist das kostet die leute
so viel zeit dass ihr mich furchtbar
deswegen also das doch gar keine wertung
da weil bewertung freuen uns überhaupt
nicht und ist zunächst mal reinschauen
doch partners